Nux king okay I'm still trying to get
the edge on whatever wzo okay we have a
Keynes gambit but do I know how to play
it is it each for I think it's each for
I'm not gonna look at what John said
earlier cuz that would be slightly
unfair
except I I have a feeling this is just a
really dubious opening but he said
something about sacking I left three and
then later sacking about out of seven so
yeah hopefully I'm not gonna butcher
this let's be patient with the next sack
to do it at the right time let's do this
sacking a pond maybe this move to keep
in mind I'm down a piece I'm about to me
down to pieces I played g4 here ah see
choose hanging I guess I could sack now
that's probably just terrible though and
if I play g4 takes Oh Queen can the
Queen take on c2 i almost trapped the
queen
okay um Yolo Yolo I was caught using
this and that none I'll sack and then
I'll take in Kassel and try and make
John proud okay so whites are black
traits first know if that makes a huge
difference
still waiting for this move but black is
scared yeah I don't want to sack yet
[Music]
yes there's no reason to FAC enough
southern now like the Queen's on g7
let's take on Tucson but it's still oh
no maybe it now it's not not still
lingering its each six remove each six
is a move alpha zero would be proud
forgot about that so do I take I could
take and castle it's such a weird
position to Castle but it makes sense I
once I file a control I want a file
control as well hmm do I sack the
exchange now let's play let's play this
restricted move preventing black black
hasn't moved the King I don't think and
now I'm pregnant to take and take even
take me being there there's a lot of fun
threats
meanwhile the Knights completely
dominated by the bishop so everything's
pretty much stuck is the Bishop spin the
King stuck if it moves here then there's
a file pin night moving year doesn't
help the rooks are the play this is nice
so Knight f6 so do I sack more I could
take on I can just win back the piece
knife six is not a bad move Bishop e5 I
considered that idea but okay all can go
back later let's um let's take on u6 so
this pawn is gonna survive for a long
time hopefully
oh there's King f7 I might have to sack
the exchange or like I guess when two
pieces for a rook then I'll be down the
exchange looking f7 I take twice and
then probably just keep improving that
oh there's also this line rook here this
looks more more fun and then this move
now the king is slightly on sheltering
now this move may be turning mate Wow 94
so how do i mate say this threatening
this also threatening maybe this the
knight takes I just mate
does this a stake okay life is very good
and see away and that's just push up on
this is hard to deal with for black this
is a fun game I play this move
threatening meet now ooh
forgot about that okay I have to go for
this
oh hello - uh yeah the world wow this is
still not easy to win especially given
the time situation No
never underestimate that kind of the
hard way here but I should still win
somehow they had the dirty flag well
what are we again I thought I was got
comfortable and then somehow I wasn't
winning because I lost my pawn I alpha 0
pawn thanks John yeah I didn't find the
right moment to sack on f7 Bishop e5
yeah Bishop e5 Windsor rook but this
just looked more and more like torture
for black and Bishop e5 it around this
moment runs into f6 so definitely an
idea what to do yeah still trying to
make John proud I'll have to off to try
and repeat that opening at some point
thanks Brian for the whole of world bits
in san san japan's a-- 11 with a sub
double museo is not usually is usually
not each for uh louis you just solo g
for like unprovoked interesting playing
the virus I still want a Stafford gambit
looks like that five whatever this is
called
we'll have we'll have a reverse musio
thing so you don't play so I'm not gonna
play h5 I just allow this and I sack
tonight
I'll probably just castle play c6 and d5
yeah it's slightly unexpected and then I
take here at some points do I do it the
next move maybe oh no my opponent higher
rated than previously to play somewhat
soundly oh it's so hard to resist
okay have to make John proud again and
take here so it's like a Museo because I
sacked one and then I sacked another
thing this is very much outside my
comfort zone but okay I'm threatening
this to win a queen if this I have this
if this I assume there's checks also
ready to castle and this move to let's
start with this because I'm threatening
the pawn and the king
I'll probably just castle next what to
do take on c2 first let's just Castle
King safety first
hmm
the thing is White's gonna give back a
piece at some point so I have to be
careful play this move and there's so
much pressure
yep might moves anywhere I'll I'll have
some fun discoveries Wow
do i soccer Queen probably not
rook g5 is a good move kind of forgot
about that I'm like we need six the fd3
I can take whose now I'm fretting this
which I think the opponent missed and
now the tack wow I won in 16 moves
reverse double musio or whatever we call
it wasn't nice interesting me I mean
stockfish would probably just insult me
stockless let's get insulted
yeah just hey John thanks for the 5,000
proud bits
yeah stock fish is not impressed bow but
after Kingi - it's it's a position it's
not easy to play like d3 the best move
is not easy because you you subject to
yourself - like all of these discoveries
yeah one wrong move and then Camino it
was still somehow better but it was just
more fun to play as black okay those
Knights